what's up everyone and what is this
PewDiePie playing video games
oh oh oh playing Magic the official game
of virgins we're about to hit point name
rank I'm playing with my genius deck
angry white people which is a white red
aggro deck if you guys haven't played
magic before I'm sure this will be very
confusing but it's basically it's a
video game so that's all you need to
know okay great
we've actually been playing magic a
couple of people in Brighton like PJ
Joel sometimes Dave comes down as well I
am I missing anyone I don't know we'll
keep this by the way it's been really
fun really nostalgic I used to play
magically when I was a kid and I didn't
under all my god you got destroyed
nice I didn't even we're getting
closer to ply it to them see this is how
easy magic is for me people just see me
and they run away in fear I don't even
have to play the game to assert my
dominance that's how good we are next
victim
what the hell just happened there did he
just look at his hand and hit it now
this is not a great hand but I'll keep
it just because I don't like getting
crippled and that's not against cripples
maybe a little bit all right great we're
playing against red they are pushed
official deck of insults do I play a
down tow and let it get killed what do I
do here
well are you next time we can play
that so we'll play this guy that's what
that's the idea
he's got three mana risk factor now one
two three four five six seven eight
you'll have to dis why is he playing
risk factor now why if you decline your
role I will mix these up if I decline he
draws cards okay guys I wouldn't have
done it if you had won two mana less
just so he doesn't do this spectacle but
now he's gonna be like Oh huh-uh
I got her no you didn't I have I have a
gross stuff too buddy look at that what
are you gonna do by that look we're
almost the same now almost don't
worry boys we have a roll week
enforcement what are you gonna play now
again okay so one two three four five
six seven okay why is he playing risk
factor well take action right we'll take
the damage Kazemi
I think he's gonna get what does he have
a spectacle I know I went against what I
just said don't spectacle me please
don't spec to my Legion war box oh he
didn't okay we're good you don't
understand what you've just done one two
three four five six seven eight nine so
the question here is did we wait for
history Banali and now we don't I need
to start doing damage I will attack with
everyone all right men what do we mentor
guess one of my boy one of my green boy
do you feel the pain drop another risk
factor I dare you okay watch me get
three Thunderbolts ain't nothing out of
respect I gave you the clip okay well we
won the game so now I decline so you can
enjoy your cards alright you can have
them congratulations
what the hell is this I've never seen
this if he plays a 41 alright you can
only really do one more thing incredible
nice nice good job thinking what do I do
oops oh that's too bad
well played though idiot so hot in here
we're almost there one more and we're
platinum baby we're no longer in sub
zero IQ tier a lot of times when I play
magic I seriously question myself if I'm
actually
because you notice as soon as you make a
mistake in this game and he does hurt so
much power fooled we're playing against
someone called powerful whoa
okay I'm keeping this hand it's actually
not that great but we can remove some
and the green boy can be like
hey what's up and this guy I hit the art
of this it makes me uncomfortable
what is that mustache I don't like it
it doesn't look even it looks like it
goes all the way here and then he just
stops here and like what is he getting
hunted by he doesn't even look hunted I
like his shirt though but then again
he's sure has checkers here and stripes
here like what's up with that all right
that's all I got about that
that's my lowell just click okay god
damn it your opponent is choosing to
keep their hand don't think too hard
people are so goddamn slow in this game
sometimes you're just sitting there like
alright so Playland please play a line
just play a line and do your thing I
don't know what people do while they
playing because they ain't playing if it
takes him this long your opponent kept
he decided to keep it well
congratulations well what was my choice
it was stupid
does he start as well that's bet
let's see how powerful you are mister oh
god it's red again I really think I was
just lucky last game that he didn't oh
god I just realized just so he feels
intimidated by my old my little dude
over here that's right I'm not at the
Fareed back what you got about that
please tell me he didn't draw any lines
that's my only way of winning
they'll play the land night oh wait it
wasn't his turn yet there we go
interesting okay
well things could definitely be worse do
I want to get rid of that right away
yeah I don't want to take a bunch of
damage hello I don't think we're gonna
win this one I can feel that already
like I lost too much tempo and I'm not a
control deck so like what am I even
doing at this point if I play legions
lining now and hunted witness then next
turn I can get legions landing switch
but it doesn't matter cuz I'll have your
heroic forces anyway but if I play this
I'll just lose one of my goblins
essentially and it won't really matter
so I know this is a bit weird but at
least I'll have some defense
why am i playing defensive a girl I
don't don't act okay now cast your shock
on my hunted oh you don't have one
that's too bad
oh you're not even gonna attack what
okay
all right well I guess we're both idiots
now the move of the century watch me
whip green boy is he gonna shock you
don't shut green boy ain't nobody
shocking my boy okay and then we
transform leaders landing and next turn
you will smoke a cute guess what's in
Sweden you shocked my green boy oh now
I'm very angry plan completely ruling
that son of a gun he has to mana though
he's stuck her mana I didn't even
realize
all right well green boy is still very
angry all right well you can't do
anything so I might as well get rid of
these you can't do anything just click
thank you hello we're back what's up
okay
now the play of the century coming right
up look at this the fact that we haven't
won against this King guy is just
pathetic because honestly hey he doesn't
have any land
oh he just took it what a Chan Lee Jin
his back boy what are you sitting on
another one
attack with your Pyromancer please Oh
what is this what a weird game you know
that boy has a shot alright well now
they're all pathetic and I don't like it
but I'm gonna just to show that I have
the bigger penis we'll keep that oh it's
so confusing
all right you will block with that and
then you will let the rest go like a
good one okay and we get some health
which is good help is good we have no
cards what are you doing
this is oh Jesus he's got a ball of
stuff it's not a ball it just hit me I
always thought it was like a sponge of
jellyfish ball well I'm disappointed
yes okay let's do some math you can
block three of my strongest which are
all so one two three one two three
four he doesn't die this turn
I think we should god I
hope this is not the wrong move I just
think he's gonna do one damage to my me
it doesn't matter if I would be dead
that would be dead already
okay all right and then another one of
these and then we're all in baby here
we'll have one helpless but he won't
have any wizards which is nice
and I don't think he can do anything
okay what are you gonna do that's right
by
oops oops there it is ah
okay look at that one more game it's
just this is the third time on one game
from diamond and I saved the lava for
that's the best part
yeah I'll save it shut the up
how overpowered is that cards
it's insane
angular you are white people I swear to
God the only weakness the one weakness
angry white people have are angry angry
people basically mana reg if I play
against them King mana red for the third
time I'm going for Diamond I'm
gonna be so SuperDuper pissed okay let's
go let's freakin do this okay hello so
you get back say it oh oh it's my turn
okay we're gonna assert our dominance
and play leaders Landing I realize I
should always play Legion sign it first
because I don't want to risk you get
encountered which could definitely
happen it's like oh it's a gate deck oh
that is very scary because I think
definitely I can beat a gate think I
would sky make sure I don't make any
misplace so I can't play anything else
this turn but this
and I'll play this tent and then go
forth my little vamp there you go we won
I've lost it I'm so orange what is
happening I've lost against the with one
foam on I swear to God a health I mean
why do I have this in my deck now why
you ask because I'm so sick of King mono
I look like an something I look like
something my my shirt is definitely not
yellow let's just put it down dude we're
gonna do two damage now this changes
everything
data blaze coming right up boom boom
boom all gone
okay play it there it is oh I'm shocked
you should have waited till next time Oh
your dingus seriously you can wait one
second turn
all attack maybe he has another one I
would can make me cry but it would be
pretty funny if he doesn't have another
one I would laugh ha if you have us
another one I will scream please hello
please like I'm hitting you up with
hello it's over here
please please do you understand this I
just need to win this game but let you
win any other game afterwards if he hits
me with a gate ablaze
that's not what it's called Lizzie it is
what an epic name and hits me with the
hello there's hope in the world there's
hope and please I think maybe he has won
but he's worried about he could be
worried about getting ligament what am I
saying I feel like I might as well play
this cuz there's really no other move I
can make creatures you control getting
lifelink I really really don't need this
at all I don't know what he's thinking
about countering it what what it's a
copy targeting is worse about we come at
a monocle that you may choose new target
for the coffee does that mean we get it
yeah
all right I'm confused I might as well
give it to ourselves and he'll mentor
King Hearts
now we're gonna play lead-ins Landing is
there any point of playing lead-ins
Landing no there isn't because we can
easily play it next turn and if he hits
me up with another gate DeBlase I will
cry I never been this close good game oh
hello thank you
finally diamond I've been trying all day
like a virgin loser diamond yeah
yeah I mean I don't care it's whatever I
really don't care
honestly like diamond is pretty easy to
game it's whatever
holy I feel so good
yeah now we're going for mythic
baby easy angry white people no one can
smash him no one can stop angry white
people this is my deck I'm gonna link it
if anyone wants to play with it
it's literally nothing special but it's
angry white people damn that feels good
see who said I wasn't a gamer why do I
look so freakin crazy
I play real man screams all right Lee
would like to be one more of this maybe
this is completely incoherent and people
don't know anything about magic I don't
know but I had fun so that's there's
that bye